in the first part that we looked at
already of the passions of the Soul what
deart was doing was laying out the
connection between the mind and the body
and telling us how that worked and you
remember that that a passion was a way
in which
body brain in particular acted
on the mind
so this is the action and the mind feels
a passion in response they card had all
this weird stuff about animal spirits
that we're not going to worry about
anymore from this point because we all
know that you know it's electrical
impulses and the brain is a hell of a
lot more complicated than he per
perceived it as being because he didn't
have microscopes we know about neurons
all that sort of stuff what we're really
interested in
is
what's actually going on with these
passions or these
feelings or
emotions and we are going to skip over
the parts where he's talking about like
how it affects the heart and
um changes the circulation of the blood
or any of that sort of stuff we're not
going to be concerned with that because
his we know that his science his
physiology is actually inaccurate so we
don't need to focus on that what we do
want to focus on is what else we can
take from this work which is how these
passions
arise and what sort of modes or
manifestations they have and what we're
supposed to do with them because
ultimately this book whether you realize
it or not is about how to live a good
life it's not just about you know how
does the mind and the body interact we
want to know that so that we can
actually have a good interaction between
body body and mind said body and B so
um he gives us a list of the
passions and he's going to come up with
six main passions or
feelings Wonder or amazement or uh
astonishment
um Love
hatred
desire joy
and
sadness now those are pretty pretty
important right and you guys can all
identify these when when they occur in
yourself and when they occur in other
people like if I were to show you um
images with uh people's faces could you
could you identify somebody who's
feeling astonishment as opposed to say
desire probably right what are some
signs some facial signs of this stuff
occurring eyebrows go up your eyes get
bigger you know start paying attention
close more closely desire people tend to
move towards things or away from
things can you tell the difference
between love and hate yeah pretty pretty
easy um now what's missing what don't we
have on
there do we have all the uh emotions
that that we
feel that you
feel yeah fear fear is not on there um
so that's kind of a
big gap what
else yeah anger
mhm anger is anger exactly the same
thing as hatred not not exactly
but
um any others that that you think are
particularly glaring by their
Omission uh that play a role in your
life or is this if we add fear and anger
is that pretty
complete now deart will add those but
he's going to say that these are the
most basic ones everything else is built
up out of
those so you know if you look for
example at his treatment of Wonder he
say
say what is Wonder well when we first
encounter some object and it surprises
us and we find it no that means you know
different from what we we knew or what
we thought it would be this brings it
about that we wonder we're astonished at
it and he says all this can happen
before we know whether the object is
beneficial to us so you hear a new
song on the radio and you are amazed I
remember when I first heard I was
driving with my sister we driving down
for Christmas vacation
and I heard uh a Portis Head song and I
i' never heard it before and I don't
remember we were listening to some
Chicago station and I and I was like wow
that's really amazing stuff was back in
the 90s so that was kind of new back
then um and she ended up buying me the
the album because you could tell how how
engrossed I was in it that was something
like what dickart was calling wonder and
then there was you know love and joy
involved as well so when you hear some
music that makes you like sit up and
take notice or when you see an
advertisement or when
you um encounter a person and even if
you've gotten to know them you see a new
side of them and then you're surprised
by it that's Wonder yeah what you going
to um I just trying to think of how to
word it but there's no there's nothing
up there that kind of describes
contentedness like ah you're not not
everyone is always uh joyful or sad that
sometimes just kind like a
neutral yeah and that was pretty that
was something Dart was talking a lot
about wasn't it with Elizabeth that's
going to be sort of like a a state of
Joy but a settled calm state of of Joy
um this is where decart is is going to
be different than say some of the stoics
or or some of the epicurian where it's
like just you want to be calm and not
feel anything right deart thinks that
real contentment is feeling Joy so that
that's a very good point now
here's what I wanted to show you with
this so deart says all right we feel
this this feeling of
wonder how does that manifest itself and
that's where he goes into all these
other descriptions he talks about esteem
and
contempt so we don't use this word
esteem very much except in
self-esteem and when you have
self-esteem what does that
mean does it mean you like
yourself it's not exactly
that like confident kind okay yeah we
often associate with confidence we want
we want to develop self-esteem in in
high school and kids so that they they
have more confidence and they can
approach their work better but what is
it to actually esteem
yourself it's to Value
yourself to um he says wonders joined to
either esteem or contempt depending on
whether we wonder at how big the object
is how you know metaphorically so it can
be valuable or how small so we can
esteem
ourselves giving rise to the passion of
uh pride and the corresponding Behavior
or we can contem ourselves we can look
down on ourselves it's kind of
interesting to think about that in order
to look down on yourself you kind of
have to be above yourself in some
respect don't you for for the you that
you're looking down on I'm so stupid I'm
I'm so ugly pick whatever people say to
themselves there's the you that's saying
that which is sort of placing itself
above the you that's actually suffering
that and somehow these are both the same
thing can we do this with with other
people yeah we can we can esteem or
scorn them and like he says when we
esteem or contemn other objects we
regard as free causes capable of doing
good and evil that' be you and me free
causes we're able to choose our actions
our esteem becomes veneration and our
simple contempt becomes scorn now
veneration again not a word we use an
awful lot scorn I think you you guys
understand when we again look down on
somebody and say they're no good um we
have all sorts of words that person's
indor that person's you know stupid um
they're they're worthless that sort of
thing we're looking down on people in
that case we're scorning them and that's
that's an expression of this this
emotion this
passion then he talks about love and
hatred why do we love and hate
things it's something we don't ask
ourselves a
lot D cart says when we love something
we love it because we think of it as
good with regard to us so in a very
trivial way I love my coffee right um if
I come to be friends with
you and you know we we develop a deep
you know abiding friendship I don't love
you the way I love my coffee right at
this point in the semester if we think
those are the identical forms of Love or
something something wrong um also I you
know I I shouldn't love my cat if you're
really my friend I should love you in a
way that goes beyond loving my cat
because you're a different kind of thing
you actually are a free cause you're a
you're a human being um but we love
those who we see as being beneficial or
good with regard to us so why do I love
coffee is it is it good for me to drink
as much coffee I drink about two pots a
day it strike you as a good thing to
do based on your knowledge of human
physiology a bit too
much maybe even a pot a day is a bit too
much
um I love the taste that's what I love
about the coffee I love the fact that if
I don't have it I have a hard time
staying
awake um but I don't love it like I love
my cat or like I love um um reading
philosophy or like I love you know great
papers or things like that um how is how
is reading a good student paper
beneficial to
me that's kind of a weird thing to think
about yeah shows you that you're
effectively teaching material and that
they're able to
think on it yeah I I I guess so um a
student is what deart is calling here a
free cause so I can provide you with you
know the opportunities to to do well but
then it's your actual
choice to do all the work that's
required to do well I don't really teach
you so much as lead you up to a bunch of
things and then say hey look at this
what do you make of this and what are
you going to do with this and then you
actually do the work required for that
and I I know like it I actually get
something out of it it's hard for me to
figure out what the hell that is um but
as I'm reading good papers I'm like yeah
this is you know this is great stuff um
sometimes it's hard to figure out
exactly how it's beneficial what do we
hate if we if what we love is what's
beneficial for us we hate things that
are harmful to us
so sometimes we don't realize them as
harmful again I'm drinking two cups of
coffee every day on average that's
actually harmful to me right and I don't
I don't hate the coffee as a matter of
fact I actually love the coffee but
that's just cuz I don't know any better
or what knowledge I have is not actually
getting put into effect what are things
that you do hate that you you actually
are pretty clear
about um are any of you ticked off that
this storm is coming in and that it may
actually extend your travel times to get
back to your homes for
Thanksgiving does that tick you
off I'm ticked off about the fact that
it's going to extend my time just
getting back home and I I live just up
the road none of you are actually like
upset about
that big
storm it would be perfectly reasonable
for you to feel a sense of hatred
towards that you know that storm it
seems kind of unreasonable because it's
just weather right but the we're talking
about passions here we're talking about
feelings
emotions um it's getting in your way
it may how many of you have to drive
back are any of you driving back the
rest of you are taking the train or
planes or train trains are are not bad
planes there you might have some some
trouble because it doesn't take much to
ground them right yeah um and that's the
busiest uh travel day of the year so so
you actually would have more cause to be
ticked off about the storm than those
who are taking trains because trains are
pretty pretty reliable car somewhere in
between right um but we we don't like
things that that uh affect us negatively
what about
desire desire Day card says is for the
future whereas we feel love and hatred
in the present and and wonder in the
present when we desire something we
desire what we don't have or we desire
the future possession of what it is that
we we do have he says I take time into
account um all desire looks forward not
only a desire to acquire some future
good or avoid some future threatening
evil but a desire to stay in one's
present state of having some good or
lacking some evil so do you desire to be
healthy how many of you are healthy
right now all of you should be raising
your hand at your age but you know um do
you want to stay
healthy okay so that's that's about a
future that doesn't yet exist
um and it leads you to doing certain
thing
it can motivate you what are things you
desire not to happen to you say oh
here's a good example what would be the
worst Christmas present uh for somebody
to give you that would like really
bother you to to get more school what's
that more school work more school
work it's hard to conceive of how that
would be possible but let's say you had
some relative that could somehow make it
that all of your classes were
retroactively like thrown into suspense
and you had to do one essay more for
each class and then you open up like you
know the gift and it's it reads there
and you're like what the hell is
this what you're feeling if you think
about that is
aversion an aversion is a desire not a
desire against it's it's also about the
future
um now notice what else he can call out
of this
hope anxiety jealousy confidence and
despair we we didn't have those up here
right we didn't have jealousy that's a
big one too isn't it so what are these
he says if we think about these um when
we desire something we can look at How
likely the outcome is if we feel that
the outcome is likely then we feel a
sense of hope don't we all of you right
now I think have a legitimately founded
sense of hope about passing this class
getting you know hope about all your
classes but I don't actually know um and
then you know getting on with with uh
finals week getting out of here coming
back next semester um that's founded on
some basis right you're not just sort of
pulling that out of the
air um that's that's a outcome that you
see as as likely when you don't see
something as likely then you feel a
sense of
anxiety are any of you feeling a sense
of anxiety about any of your exams
coming
up um you're you're worried about
whether you're going to be up to
tackling that or whether something else
might come along and screw things up for
you you know whether your jerk roommate
will like keep you from being able to
study whether you'll be able to
concentrate when you need to that's a
sense of anxiety and that is coming from
worry about the the future
um jealousy is a type of anxiety dayart
thinks and then he talks about when
these things become
extreme When Hope becomes extreme it
becomes confidence where you're like
guaranteed this is going to happen even
though it's not guaranteed right you
feel like it's guaranteed you feel a
sense of confidence the opposite end of
that is despair when you feel like it
can't possibly go my
way and why why is that affecting you
like a passion because you have
desires um he also talks about hoping
and fearing things that
um depend on us to some degree and we
can feel indecision we can feel what you
call shrinking
reluctance fear courage boldness all
these things are things we can
feel if we look at some of these other
things there's modalities for that too
talks about remorse when you feel a
sense of
remorse that's a type of sadness isn't
it you're sad because you did something
wrong or made a bad choice and you're
it's sort of past
looking
um what are joy and sadness then let's
look at these so he says the thought of
a present good and when he says thought
don't just think imagination think about
your your perception of things because
when you're sensing things what you're
actually sensing are thoughts in your
mind they're thoughts of you know a row
of students or of a clock or of a camera
you those are thoughts and when you're
feeling things those are also thoughts
in your mind so when you're experiencing
some sort of good you feel a sense of
joy you know you get the test back you
got an A on the test you feel happy
right
um you get out of here beat the storm
you know you can see that you're riding
the train and as you're going you can
see the the storm front behind you you
know just sort of keeping Pace you feel
a sense of Joy you're like I I got past
it um somebody you love gives you
something nice or you know somebody
you're attracted to you know calls you
up you feel a sense of Joy um what is
sadness then
so a sense of joy is thought of a
present good what is what is sadness
then do you
think something bad right feeling it is
being
present you get the test back and it's a
d now you feel sad right um You God you
know hopefully this isn't going to be
the case but I'm going to use it as an
example you get what where are you
flying out like New York or JFK okay JFK
is
a wow that's that's I fly out of there
too and it's no fun right you get the
JFK well let's actually think about the
the things that that you would in a
cartisian sense make you sad you get
there and the lines are just forever
right and there's only two security
stations open and you're like man I'm
going to be stuck in this line for two
hours um now you you actually get
through security what could go wrong
after that stop you oh that's security
they take you into the other room
immigration stuff okay yeah that that
that I forgot about that um they you've
been selected for how do they put it a
random
search uh and now you're looking at your
boarding pass and you're like crap I'm
going to miss my flight and you're
feeling a sense of what deart would call
sadness because it's it's a present evil
it's a present bad thing for you and um
you know they they bring you in the room
and they're like you know scowling at
you and you're like man these people
think I'm doing something wrong now you
feel sad about that too they finally let
you out you're racing to your gate you
get there and they close the gate oh
that would be that would be really bad
cuz then the plane's actually like
taking on I I was going to make it
something less like um you get there and
and you you know rushed like you had to
run down the entire terminal and you
find out it's an hour delay and then
you're like what the hell am I going to
do for an hour now you know um then you
go over to the kiosk you get yourself
something to eat you get yourself
something to read you put your
headphones in and you start feeling a
sense of Joy again a sense of well-being
these are very you know everyday
circumstances um you know you you try to
start your car and it doesn't start now
you're sad right uh you get out there
you start your car after worrying that
it wasn't going to start now you're
happy s of sense of good
so we have all these um feelings and he
also talks about um how we might feel
about goods for other
people um when we think of good or bad
things as belonging to others we can
judge them as deserving it he says
worthy or unworthy deserving it or not
deserving it so is it the case that
sometimes people get things they don't
deserve in this world you ever
experienced that yourself you see that
happen with other people too
right now if it's a good thing and they
actually do deserve it how do you feel
when you see them getting it if you feel
that they deserve it does it make you
feel
good you know um think about charitable
giving this is the time of year where
people are going to do things like give
turkeys away um and it's going to a poor
family and if you feel that that you
know it's a good thing for poor people
to actually get a break once in a while
and get a free turkey then it makes you
feel good inside when when that happens
you feel a sense of Joy what if you feel
like poor people are scum and don't
deserve it at all then you see that
turkey like if you're the Grinch you
know remember the the story about the
Grinch har is twoo sizes too small right
um how do you feel
that feel a sense of sadness but it but
it manifests as something else
hat well not not hatred yet
Envy that's what Envy is when you see
somebody else enjoying something and you
don't want them to enjoy it because you
feel that it's it's
undeserved um what if some something bad
happens to somebody else and you feel
like they don't deserve it what do you
feel towards them
then we have a couple different words we
use um
um would be some examples again you know
we see charity coming out of
this feel pity
right or Compassion or empathy or we
have you know nicer words but pity is
really what we're feeling pity is a
sense of
sadness at somebody else having some
Misfortune that they don't deserve you
could feel this towards your family
members for example you see
um Dart doesn't talk about this but this
would be a great example your your
brother your sister your cousin goes
through a terrible
breakup you maybe they're married and
they they get divorced or maybe they're
you know engaged and the other person
breaks off the engagement and they're
really heartbroken about it and you're
like um they didn't deserve that that
other person's a jerk you feel a sense
of sadness you feel pity for them but
that's coming out of sadness all these
are the basic basic
emotions um Dart then says why is my
list different from everybody
else's like Thomas aquinus we didn't
read this but Thomas aquinus has a list
of emotions as well and he says um I'm
parting company with almost everybody
who's written about the passions but
I've got good reason for this
says I don't know anything that implies
that the soul has these you know
erasable and conis parts that we saw
with Thomas cuz I would say the soul is
two Powers the power to desire and the
power to be annoyed but it seems to me
the soul has the power to do all sorts
of things to feel Wonder love hope
anxiety it has the power to feel all
these different human emotions and every
single one of these is a different kind
of
thought that's why we feel it
differently but they can all be reduced
to these six basic
passions so I am going to skip over some
of these these discussions um where he's
talking about like the blood the heart
you know we don't we don't we're not
interested in that what we're interested
in is the stuff where he says what's the
definition of the
emotion what causes it and then you know
how can we use it bless you so let's
start with wonder wonder he says is an
impression in the brain which represents
the object is unusual and therefore
worthy of special consideration so this
is something that you've had since you
were a baby you know uh when you were a
baby you actually wondered at just about
everything because everything was
totally new to you right and as you got
older you wondered at many other things
because you expanded the realm of your
experience and you're still experiencing
Wonder all all the time
um now we can Wonder strongly or we can
Wonder
weakly and sometimes we can go wrong
with with wonder he
says um he says the passions are useful
only because they strengthen and prolong
thoughts it's good for the soul to have
which might otherwise be wiped
out they can do us harm though too so
when when do we need Wonder this you
know like stopping and going oh
um your life would be kind of incomplete
without that right but does it also
serve some purposes for you remember
Wonder makes you
stop and like pay
attention what are what are some
situations in which that could be really
really useful for
you to break yeah just discover new
things yeah you're you're right
um our entire way of life is based on
years and years of discoveries that
other people have made down to like I
mean think about the clothing that we
wear all this is manufactured somebody
had to actually figure out how to do
this and how to make this yellow and how
to make that GR gray and not just gray
but shiny gray and you know all those
sorts of things somebody actually had to
say whoa what's going on here and then
investigate it so it's very important
for that what else does it serve any
like purposes in keeping you from
getting
hurt physically yeah I guess like you're
driving and like you see something in
the road and like like a deer running
across and you're kind of like surprised
and like wonder if there's more or
something yeah that's a great example
because when we're driving especially if
we're going long distance I think a lot
of you have experienced this we start to
get that kind of tunnel vision and
especially we have music on we start we
we you know our Focus kind of drifts and
then suddenly something happens in front
of us and we're like whoa what the hell
is that right and it provided we don't
like jerk the wheel and you know go off
the road or you know step on the brakes
immediately our body is set now to sort
of evaluate new information coming in
like hey there's a herd of deer up there
uh I've got about 2 seconds before
before I hit them I better start you
know pumping the brakes and see if I can
possibly maneuver around them or wait a
second I'm in the wrong lane and there's
a truck over there coming this way um
driving is a perfect example of why we
need
Wonder
um I suppose if we were hunting and
foraging and stuff like that it' be
awfully useful for us as well
um just being you know being attentive
to to our environment developing what
they call mindfulness depends on what
deart is calling Wonder can it go wrong
for
us um he says we can have too much or
too little
Wonder so excessive wondering just you
know being surprised all the
time um that can keep us from
thinking there are some people who are
constantly reacting to their environment
and they're not able to think very
coherently or for very long
and like he says it's really this is a
interesting point it's not the stupidest
or the cleverest people who are most
given to wonder it's people in the
middle who have the the greatest
danger
um and then he says it can become a
habit when we fail to correct it he says
this passion seems to diminish with use
the more that we encounter unusual
things that we wonder at the more
accustomed we become to not wondering so
think about your training in in any sort
of thing you're experiencing something
new eventually it becomes familiar to
you you no longer Wonder at it now
you're better equipped to deal with
things like driving for example when you
you remember first learning how to drive
was it scary should have been if not
then then you're a dangerous driver you
know um and at first you felt like you
know you didn't have the feel of the car
felt very foreign to you after a while
you can like just get in a car and you
know you know exactly how things go um
when you get to my age after you've been
driving for more than half your life
it'll be like second nature to you
um now he says when it's excessive when
wonder is excessive and makes us fix our
attention solely on the first image of
the object before us without learning
anything more about it when we're just
sort of passively taking things in like
think about people who watch TV all the
time that's sort of wondering in decart
sense constantly
it it makes a person less able to focus
on
things
um he says it gives the soul a habit of
dwelling in the same way on everything
it encounters it seems the least new
that's why it's hard to cure the blind
curiosity degree disease he says some
people just always need to have
something new some new stimulation that
is having too much wonder and it becomes
a
habit um so that's good we've Ted talked
about
Wonder now let's look at these
two he tells us some more stuff about
this and what he says is kind of
interesting says love is a commotion of
the Soul caused by a movement of the
spirits okay so something going on in
our brain that impels the soul to join
itself de Volente by Will to objects
that appear to be agreeable to it so
when you love I'm going to do a little
bit of erasing here um here's
you and here's some
object when you
love you're kind of
joining
yourself to that object in your in your
mind in your feelings in your
soul
um you're connecting yourself
with hatred is a uh the opposite of this
wanting to be separated from objects
that that appear to be
harmful so you don't love just anything
you love objects that are in some
way like he says
agreeable things that are appropriate to
you sounds a little bit like Thomas
aquinus doesn't
it when we talk about natural
love um so if I love the taste of coffee
and we'll get to you know sense stuff
later um there's something in it that's
agreeable to me if I love certain music
there's something in that that's
agreeable to me if I love a person that
means that I want to be with that person
in some some
respect um could be you know romantic
where I want to be romantically attached
to this person or I want us to be you
know part of some some unit it could be
um love in terms of friendship it could
be a lot of different kinds of
love so he says what is this day volunte
he says um I'm not using this to talk
about desire I mean our consent to
considering ourselves from now on as
joined with the thing we love in such a
way as we imagine a whole of which we
are one part and the Beloved thing is
another so it it's sort of like remember
Aristophanes and the the two trying to
become the one you know the whole deart
is saying something kind of like that
love is a movement on your part that
wants to unite you with the thing that
you love wants to see you as being part
of some larger ho some larger unit
doesn't mean that you lose yourself
but it becomes part of you hatred is is
like the opposite you want that thing as
far away from you as
possible
um
so the current wants to say we have as
many kinds of love as we have
objects um so he says
consider this what ises a miser
love Miser
yeah money they're they're the ones who
are always hoarding money or greedy
people what do greedy people love money
right uh what is a a drunk love alcohol
alcohol yeah he has wine but you know
it's cuz he's in France for us it could
be beer or Jin or anything you like um
what does an ambitious person want what
do they love success success yeah he
puts Glory but I think success is a a
term that we use more we don't say I'm
aiming at glory we say I'm aiming at
success uh and then he talks about two
interesting contrasts he says a brutish
man having desire or love for a woman
that he wants to rape an honorable man's
for his friend or
mistress these are both coming from the
same basic
passion one is a brutal
thing violates another person right one
is actually sort of honoring the other
person in in the thing he says though
very different from one another these
are all alike in involving love but the
first four people love only for the
possession of the objects like being you
know wealthy being
successful um drink drinking wine uh
somebody else's body that you don't
have they don't actually have love but
only desire mixed with other particular
passions in contrast to that he says a
good Father's Love for his children is
so pure so clean and clear-cut and free
of impurities he doesn't desire to have
anything from them he's not trying to
get something from them he loves the
object for the sake of the object again
sounds a lot like Thomas aquinus doesn't
it um
he regards them as other himself and
seeks their good as he does his own he
represents to himself that he and they
together form a whole of which he is not
the better part so he often puts their
interest before his own and doesn't
shrink from sacrificing himself to to
save them an honorable man's affection
he says is like that too when you if
you're an honorable person and you love
your friends you treat your friends and
you as if you were part of some greater
whole and you treat them as if they were
the more important part you see them as
another
self um then he says a man's affection
for his mistress consists largely of
love but also as a touch of Desire
because it's a sexual relationship right
so there's a a gulf between these
different kinds of love then he talks
about affection friendship devotion I'm
going to skip over that because we don't
have that much time uh um interestingly
he says there's fewer kinds of hatred
than
love um we don't distinguish it into as
many kinds because what what do we do
when we hate something we just want to
get get it the hell away from us or get
us away from that or kill it or destroy
it or make it no longer part of the
picture then he talks about attraction
and revulsion
so what does he mean by that he says
here's a distinction we can make
when we feel something to be good or
bad we can think of it as good or bad
like with our
intellect
um take for example the boarding pass
right the boarding pass is a good thing
for you to have yes but you you looking
at the boarding pass it's not very
pretty is it they never are and you
can't like smell it smells like flowers
or something like that what's that smell
like paper yeah I'm usually like that
that crappy ink that they they put on it
uh the cheap stuff I like it smell you
like it smell yeah I love it there you
go maybe for you it has like
associations of getting to go somewhere
that you know you like um but you know
it's a good thing in your mind there's
other things where we we feel that
they're good through what we call our
internal sense so when you eat food
right it fills you up provided it
doesn't kill you because you're allergic
to it or something like that you feel
better um we realize those things as
good other things we perceive through
the senses like our eyes our ears taste
buds nose
skin those uh we represent to ourselves
as good or bad but we represent them to
ourselves as as beautiful or ugly as
aesthetically pleasing or aesthetically
unpleasing um you know think about when
you've all had clothes that didn't fit
you right at one time or another maybe
hand-me-downs or you you know you
actually grew out of them um that didn't
feel good right and then getting new
clothes something like it felt like it
fit that's what he's talking about there
or when you hear music that you really
like that you respond to and then you
hear noises that you can't
stand um that's what he's talking about
or when you're looking at people and and
some people look beautiful and some
people look ugly um we are we are
experiencing these in terms of love and
hatred but it's a different
modality uh
um he says something is beautiful or
ugly if it is represented as agreeable
to our nature contrary to it by our
external senses chiefly by our sense of
sight and this can be stronger than the
love or hatred that we feel through our
minds or through our internal
senses
um I'm going to run through the desire
stuff very quickly he says we can divide
desire up into as many things as we want
to desire we can also understand desires
working both ways if you you don't
desire to be late right you desire not
to be late for care your flight because
it's more critical than than a train
where you could like cash the next train
or car where you can start whenever you
like um that's still a desire deart
wants to say aversion is a a desire um
now we have some uh
desires that arise from revulsion and
and attraction from our senses
um and he's got some really interesting
examples here you know he says we can be
triggered to feel revulsion merely by
the touch of an
earthworm think about when you pick up a
worm it's kind of gross isn't it anybody
into that sort of thing most of you are
not into that sort of thing if if if I
gave you the option of my putting a a
cup full of earthworms into your hand or
not doing that you'd all take the not
doing it right because it's
gross that's what he means by revulsion
um we also have desire beginning from
attraction we're attracted to all sorts
of things you I'm going to use a
nonvisual one for
example how many of you have been up to
the culinary yet so far okay so you guys
have walked around on campus
right what besides it being a beautiful
campus aesthetically what do you notice
about that place with your senses that's
different than say this
campus
I don't
know like what do you mean well think
about your you got hearing sight smell
taste touch site is pretty much the same
right food is better once you actually
sit down and eat it now you're it
doesn't really feel
like
okay you get out of the parking lot
right you've parked in the parking
structure you're walking towards the the
building that has you know uh most of
the restaurants in it perhaps um
what do you smell food yeah and not just
food you smell all these different
wonderful odors of spices and onions you
know
caramelizing and you know stock being
made and you smell something a little
bit like that of the cafeteria over
there but not anything on a scale of of
the culinary and as you're walking
towards there you should start to get
hungry you should start to feel like man
I'm going to eat something
good that's natural that's what he's
calling attraction then you actually get
in there and everything is you know very
pretty and presented well it's not quite
you know the cafeteria here has improved
a lot by the way compared to how how it
used to be you guys actually have some
some pretty nice stuff the chef by the
way CIA Grant um the executive chef all
right let's let's go on to Joy and
sadness so he says um we we feel these
these passions when we have some sort of
belief whether it's a true belief or
false belief that we're experiencing
some sort of
good um sadness arises from the belief
that one has some sort of evil or defect
and what he says here is really
interesting often times we feel Joy or
sadness Without Really knowing why we're
feeling
it if we feel desire we know why we're
feeling desire because we can point
towards I want that or I want not that
same thing with love and hatred and
wonder you know when we are surprised at
something we what we're surprised at we
may not know exactly what it is but we
can say yeah that thing over there joy
and sadness and this goes to your your
your question about contentment it's
something a bit more
Global he
says we often feel joyful or sad without
being able to get a clear view of the
good or evil that causes this feeling
why this happens when the good or evil
makes its impression in the brain
without the soul coming into it
sometimes because the good or evil only
involves the body
think about um the contentment that
comes with feeling
comfortable these these small things
that go into like oh for for example um
how many of you are looking forward to
going home to not necessarily even see
your relatives but to be in the place
where you grew
up surprisingly few of you or the rest
of you
anxious um when you go in like maybe
they kept your old
room um or you know you're used to the
living room or something like that there
are there parts of the house or
apartment that you particularly like
that you are going to be looking forward
to going to when you sit down there and
everything is familiar to you and it's
very comfortable you're going to feel
what dayart is calling a sense of Joy
you're not going to be thinking about it
at all probably not even after us
talking about it here you're going to
forget about all this your body is going
to settle into you know your favorite
couch or the view that you're used to
having and you're going to feel good
about
it then again maybe they'll move the
stuff around and you won't find that and
you'll be like what the hell happened
here everything's out of place but you
won't actually say this you'll just have
a kind of global feeling of that of Joy
or
sadness
um I'm going to skip over the discussion
of of of pain and pleasure and how those
fit in he talks a little bit more about
this he says young people often take
pleasure in undertaking difficult tasks
and running great risks even when they
don't look at this as a source of profit
or Glory the thought that the
undertaking is difficult forms in their
brain an
impression when joined with the
impression they could form if they
thought it a good thing to feel
sufficiently courageous happy skillful
causes them to take pleasure in doing so
I I don't think this just applies to
young people I think this applies to all
of us when we're doing things that we're
actually good at it feels good
right like if you're good at working out
if you do it regularly that feels good
doesn't it push the bar you know you got
a lot of weight on it you're doing with
good
form um those of you who are athletes
know exactly what I'm talking about um
or musicians or anything like that on
the other hand when you're experiencing
difficulty with these sorts of things
you feel a sense
of
discontent of sadness
right now he he talks about all sorts of
other stuff here that I'm totally skip
over having to do with you know the
blood moving around and all that CU I
want to get ahead to where he talks
about I'm actually going to skip over
the signs of the passions that's
interesting stuff but what are these
passions good for so we we talked about
Wonder it's a good thing to actually
like be surprised so you can pay
attention to stuff and then you know get
yourself out of trouble or take
opportunities that that or you know
think about how to discover things
um what are love and hatred good for
what are what is the point to
them well there's
there's couple issues involved
here there are two
concerns
one of these has to do with
knowledge is the
passion
based on true
knowledge and the other one I'm just
going to say has to do
with feeling
good has a good
thing
let's actually start with the second
Dart
thinks that on the
whole love is better to feel than
hatred and joy is better to feel than
sadness would you would you agree with
that or is any you know anybody here
like they love to
hate I suppose if you're like an
Internet troll or something like that
then then that would that would fit in
but then you're actually just derive
pleasure from being upset um it feels
good to be United in in your feelings to
something that you consider to be
good think about the good feeling about
being on a team when you think that the
team is actually doing the right thing
or being involved in a project that's
bigger than you that you see as valuable
that feels really really
good um think about the feeling of love
that you have towards some other people
in terms of of your friends in terms of
your pets in terms
of your parents um down the line perhaps
if you have them your
children that feels better than to
hate doesn't hating kind of
suck when when you hate things doesn't
that feel bad for you doesn't just feel
bad for what it is that you hate it also
feels bad for you doesn't
it what about um this is even more you
know direct joy and
sadness if you can feel Joy isn't that a
lot better than feeling sadness all the
different modes of sadness that you can
feel so all things being equal it's
better to feel good
feelings but there's there's cases where
you actually ought to feel sad right if
your
um parents die suddenly they get hit by
a bus God forbid um and now you you know
that's your that's that's your holiday
break is dealing with their death um and
and you say well you know it's better to
feel Joy than sadness so I'm just going
to do things that make me happy so I can
feel better about this and um then you
know all satisfied dart's criteria deart
would say you're
nuts um that's a case where you should
feel very very sad you should feel bad
about that and it's based on knowledge
about what's good for you and what's bad
for you there are cases where it's
appropriate to feel sadness or or hatred
if something is genuinely bad for you
um like a person for example somebody
who's abusive towards you you should
hate them dayart things it feels better
to love but if somebody's going to be
damaging to you it's better for you to
keep that person away from you and
that's what hatred helps you do you know
um
now You' got these two criteria why do
we have to be really careful with these
passions he says the passions can you
know help us out they can lead us in the
right way but um there's many things
that are harmful to the body that don't
cause sadness initially or they even
produce Joy what would be some examples
of that they make you feel good but
they're actually bad for you they're
harmful for
you for body some drugs
mhm yeah suppose if we want to say
like we want to count some things that
are just like medicine as drugs then the
sum would be appropriate there but most
of the things when we put them under the
title of drugs are things that people
take because they feel good but they're
they're usually bad for you um so may
have some good effects like you know
marijuana with the nausea the cancer
patients feel or things like that but um
and actually they found you know like
drinking glass of wine a day red wine is
good for you you know drinking three
isn't but people who tend to drink one a
day tend to drink three or four um quite
often and so you know they may make us
happy but we don't want to rely on our
passions we want to think it through
um I know I'm happy having seconds and
thirds at meals that I like is that good
for me to do every time
no no um is exercise painful when you
first start outdoing
it your body tells you I I don't really
feel like doing this elliptical but it's
good for you isn't it so you don't want
to follow your passions when it comes to
all those sort of things and he says
also the passions nearly always
exaggerate the size and importance of
the goods and evils they represent
inciting us to pursue the goods and flee
from the evils which more with more
artor in Zeal than is appropriate um
that's a lot of fancy talk for they give
us the wrong valuations of things they
make us when we feel a feeling often
times we're LED astray by our feelings
because the feelings make us think that
things are better than they are or worse
than they are like when you're
infatuated with
somebody how do you how do you feel
about them and how much time you should
spend with them and how much time you
should spend thinking about
them what's your
experience
can you get work done when you're
infatuated with
somebody I sure it's all
can't abalar couldn't either remember he
couldn't get any philosophy work done
because he's writing love songs all the
time I think the rest of you probably
have experienced this too the work you
get done is probably fairly shoddy um
maybe that work is actually more
valuable than your your feelings are
leading you to to believe maybe that
person is not so wonderful that you need
to spend all the time thinking about
them but your feelings kind of steer you
that way right so they're easy to steer
you uh in the wrong direction we talked
about anger as an example too when you
get angry with somebody you feel like
the the only thing that you want to do
the only thing that really matters is
showing them that they're wrong and you
know making them suffer in some sort of
way but if you looked at it more
objectively how would you see it is that
really that good of a of a thing is that
really so valuable compared to say
losing a friendship or looking like a
jerk in front of other people or letting
your blood pressure get out of get out
of control used that example a couple
times um probably not right so we want
to be using Reason Not relying on on the
passions we want to feel the passions
where they're helpful for
us and it is good to feel a sense of Joy
it is good to feel a sense of love we
want to have a life that includes that
but we want it to be measured
by know and reason and ultimately by
habits of a virtue so that's where we'll
end little